use the associative law of addition to
write the expression and we have let's
see a 77 plus 2 in parentheses plus 3 in
a different way simplify both
expressions to show they have identical
results so this associative law of
addition which sounds very fancy and
complicated literally means then you can
associate these three numbers in
different ways or you can add them in
different orders now let me just make
that clear so the way they wrote it
right here they wrote 77 77 plus 2 in
parenthesis and then they wrote plus 3
these parenthesis mean do the 77 plus 2
before you add the 3 so if you were to
evaluate this you would evaluate what's
in the parenthesis first so you'd say
well 77 plus 2 that's 79 so everything
in the parenthesis just evaluates to 79
and then you still have that plus 3 and
79 plus 3 is 82 so this is equal to 82
that's if you just evaluate it the way
that they gave it to us
now the associative law of addition
tells us it doesn't matter whether we
add 77 and 2 first or whether we add 2
and 3 first we can associate them
differently so this is going to be the
exact same thing
this is the exact same thing as we could
write it this way so let me write them
all 77 plus 2 plus 3 and we have no
parentheses here this is actually the
same thing as this over here because
we'd go 77 plus 2 is 79 plus 3 is 82 but
the associative law tells us well you
know what I can do 77 plus 2 Plus 3 I
could add this first and then add it to
77 it's going to be the exact same thing
as if I add these two guys first and
then add the 3 and let's let's verify
that for ourselves so 2 plus 3 is 5 so
this evaluates to 77 plus 5 77 + 5 + 77
+ 5 once again is 82 is 82 so it doesn't
matter how you associate the numbers
either way you get 82 and that's the
associative law of addition